今日もう一つポイントを言いたかったポイントがありまして
このよく世の中でこの悪いことをする人々は
まあ誰でも悪いことはしますからね
別にそんなに大げさに考える必要もないんですけど
で 人間不完全だからね
で 何か悪いことしちゃうと
なんかまあ それですごく
あの 悩んだり 後悔したりして
なんか自分がかっこいいことをしてるんだとと思っちゃうんですよ
本当に私が悪かったとかね
あれが私はすごい質が悪いなと思いますよ
このわざとこの見栄張ってこの後悔したり悩んだりする人々っていうのはなかなか治らないんですね
自分を直そうという気持ちはないんですよ
あれ自慢しているんです
自分の悪いこと 私は本当にダメでしたね
やっぱりダメです ダメな人間ですね
私は とかね それで周りは
いえいえ そんなこと言わずに頑張ってくださいとかね
あれはよくやりますよ
みんな それでどうなるかというと
本人が自分のことを結局は正当化しているんです
だからこの後悔するということで罪が多くなるんです
この反省と後悔の差がよく理解しておかないとかなりダメージ受けます
だからなんですよ 人間では誰でも失敗しますよ
こんなのも私の失敗談を聞くとみんな驚くと思います
そんなのは別に でも 私の顔を見ると一度も失敗していないような顔をしているでしょうね
一度もこの人だったら失敗したことはないだろうと
後悔しないだけなんです
失敗はないと言っちゃうと
これほど嘘が世の中でないんですよ
いくら失敗したっても
私はめげるということはしない
すぐ瞬時に ああ まあ俺がアホだからね
こんなバカなこと知っていたのに
なんでやったんですか？って
まあすぐまたやっちゃうんです
すぐそれ直すんです だから普通は全然失敗したことはないように
顔 私の顔見えませんだからね
で 一応そんな態度でいるんだからね
自分は失敗したことないような
でもそれは別に失敗したことはないという事実ではなくて
もう卒鳥ですけど やっぱり後悔して落ち込んだり
それはしない だから世の中でよくあります
ちょっと何か失敗しちゃうと
その人の人生 それからずっと暗いまんまで
何かちょっと判断ミスしちゃうと
それから死ぬまで判断ミスできてるんですね
それ直せ ちょうどいったら直せないんですよ
だっていつでもぺちゃぺちゃぺちゃぺちゃぺちゃそればっかし言ってるんだから
言って言って自分の状態を正当化する
だから失敗しちゃったら
判断ミスをしたらね すぐそれを理解してね
それはなかったことにするんですよ
そして次は二度とその問題を起こさないようにと
だから新幹線で居眠り運転したんだからといって
1ヶ月間は訓練熟練の人が運転部屋に入れておくということは答えではないんですけどね
それから忘れると 何でも 1ヶ月間
例えば子供たち なんとかちょっと不幸なことになっちゃうと
まあ集団下校やら大人と一緒に家まで連れて行くとか
それ 1ヶ月ならあります
犯人見つかっていようがなかろうが関係ない
もうそれでよろしいという
で まだ失敗するとまた同じことを繰り返してね
それはあんまりまあしょうがないかもしれませんだけどね
そういうことではなくて
もう二度と同じ繰り返しは起こさんようにと
立ち 失敗しました 失敗しましたと言っちゃうと
それが後悔であって 仏教は厳しく戒めるんです
それは後悔は罪であると
犯した罪がどんどんもう
増幅するんです それも増幅の増幅の仕方がこのあれ
あの二乗三乗とかあるでしょ
そんな分かりませんですけど
そういうやり方で増えるんですよ
そういうわけで この後悔は仏教では禁止しています
いつでも立ち直れと  関連しています
うん まあ言い出しちゃったんだから全部言いますけどね
今十7十八全部同じ意味なんでつなげているのは十八までですね
じゃあ来月は全部飛ばしちゃおうかな
では来月飛ばすために十七十八持ってますか？ あります
うん まあ時間なくなっちゃったんですからね
でもインスタントで言えます
十七 見てください イダタッパティペッチャタッパティパーパカーリウベヤッタタッパティパアパンメーカタンティタッパティビヒヨータッパティドゥッカティン
ガと
で それはイデ このタッパティっていうのは燃えているという意味なんですね
すごく それでこの世でもあの世でももう燃えると
私は悪を犯したと パーパンメーカタンディタッパティ
私は悪を犯したと燃えてしまう
悩んでしまう ビヒヨータッパティ
ものすごく燃えて燃えることになるんだと
ドゥッカティンガと 地獄に落ちたから
ドゥッカティっていうのは不幸なところに行ってからさらに悩むと
地獄って限ってはないんです
悪いことをした人が次に生まれる場合は
今よりは悪いところに生まれるんですよ
だから悪いところっていうのは今の時点で考えればいいんです
今より悪いところに行っちゃう
そうするとさらに燃えてしまうことになりますと
十八はもう反対でイダなんだと
ここで喜ぶ ペッチャなんだと
後からも喜ぶ カテプンニャオ
徳を積んだ人 ウベヤッタモウだと
どちらでも喜んでいる
プンニャンメーカタンティなんだと
私は徳を積みましたとすごく喜ぶ
美容なんだと ものすごいたくさんという
美容ってたくさんということでね
で 喜びますと 喜びます
と 生まれ死んでからいいところに行って
ものすごいさらに喜ぶと
ということで 十六の説明はしなかったんですけど
で ここで喜ぶ モウダティってのは喜びですね
ペッチャー等で喜ぶ カタプンヨ
プンニャ 徳を積んだ人がウベヤッタ
どっちでも喜んでますよと
そうモウダティ そうパモウダティ
さらにさらに喜ぶと モウダティ喜ぶ
パモウダティっていうのはさらに喜ぶかな
ディッスワカンマヴィスッダマッタの
自分の行為は清らかであるということを見て喜ぶと
今日は十 本当は十五 十六で終わるつもりでしたけど
まあ十六も まあ一つの説明で全部もう終わります
で 我々は悪いことをしちゃうと自己自慢できない
しかし 良いことをすると簡単に自己自慢できる
いわゆる自分で あ よかった
いいことをしましたと
いいことをして生きてきたんだというふうに自分で喜ぶことはできるんですね
だから今日はそこはすごく大事ですよと覚えておいてください
自分で自慢できる人生
ものすごい大事なんです
これが自然にみんなやってます
まあ子供 子供さんもやってますからね
何かちょっといいことをしちゃうと
まあ自慢するはするはもううるさくてたまらんですね
大したことでもないのに
やっぱりその時はまあ親が一生懸命褒めてあげないとね
子供は納得いかない で
まあしかし 我々はどんどん年取ったらそれを忘れるかと
そうじゃないんですね
ずっとそれがあるんです
どんどん強くなるんです
だからもう退職もして
もうやることもなくなっちゃうと
みんなもう昔話ばっかりでしょ
昔はいい仕事をしましたとかね
こういうことをしましたとかね
やっぱりそうやって自慢できない人生だったらね
かわいそうじゃないんですかね
ですから この 例えば昔人殺したこともありますよと自慢するならば
その人は本当にしっかり治ってるんです
その場合は堂々と自分が過去でやった悪いことも言うんです
こういう人間でいましたよと
だからそこら辺もそんなに問題になりません
とにかく自分で自慢できる生き方をしてほしいと
他人に向かって自慢するんじゃなくて
他人は関係ない 全くも関係ない
自分一人で自分の人生観察すると
まあ自慢できると その時も数学的にやってほしい
たった一個だけ失敗したものを取って
そればっかりガチャガチャ妄想で繰り返しちゃうと
もうバカもいいところでね
数学的じゃないんですよ
誰にでも失敗したことはいくらでもあるし
しかし 人生っていうのは失敗だけで行くわけじゃないんですよ
今まで生きてるということは
今まで生きているということなんです
ですから もう計算的に考えちゃうと
もう結構うまくいったところっていうのはいくらでもありますよ
完全に失敗だったらもうとっくに死んでるんです
ですから この数学的に
あれ あれが失敗でしたけど
これこれこううまくいったんだよとかね
ということで 我々は自分一人で自分の人生ちゃんと計算してみて
数学的に まああれ失敗
なんで失敗したんだろうね
こういうことはじゃあ今度はやらないぞとかね
そういう感じで 自分で自己自慢できる生き方をしてほしいということなんですね
それは幸福の道であると
だから これは神の神様が来てきてなくても
もうどっちでもいいんです
人間が幸福になります
その生き方をすると それが仏教のちょっとした直訴なんです
すぐ分かります やっぱりそれだったらみんな幸福になるんだよと
悪いことをしないんだよと
そこでプンニャ 徳 悪って何ですか？と
もうとっくに悪の定義がもうできてます
皆様知らないだけで 喜ぶ行為は善なんですよ
後で思い出しても喜ぶ行為は善なんです
悩む行為は不善なんです
では問題はね  1,000円のお弁当買って食べると楽しいでしょうと
あの楽しみはすぐ消えちゃうんでしょ
しかし その場合でもよく頑張っていいバイトをして
よく仕事したんだから
ちょっと余分にお金くれたと
約束よりも それでだったらちょっと美味しい弁当食べると 1,200円の弁当とか買って食べると
その時はやっぱり自分では自慢というかね
満足感って得られる やっぱりその場合でもやっぱりいい行為の結果なんですね
そこで自分が 1,000円のお弁当を誰かに差し上げたと
しちゃうと その 1,000円はもう死なないんです
ずっと幸福を作ってくれる
充実感を作ってくれる
自信を作ってくれる それ増幅させちゃうと
かなり元気な人間になってしまっちゃう
一人でこれだけ自慢したってもね
あんまり自慢にならんともっといいことをしなくちゃと
もっといいことしなくちゃったって
やっぱり仕事して それなりに収入なくちゃダメでしょうと
ということで もうもっと活発的にはなります
日本でも金自慢じゃなくて
いろんな人を助けたり
いろんないいボランティアしたりとかね
そういう人々は本当にすごいんですよ
どこにでも行くわ 何でもするわとかね
だからすごい力がある
普通 金だけを狙っている人々はものすごい腰抜けで弱くて
気が小さくて 怯えて だからといって日本人みんな怯えてるかというとそうじゃないんですよ
いろんなことに行って
もう頑張っちゃうという人々のために
別にあちこち行ったり来たりするんだから
ろくに仕事もしてないと思いますよ
でも 誰よりも元気 だからこの変わらぬどんどん増幅する幸福を作ってくれるのは徳という風に禅という風になるんです
これを例で考えましょう
例えば自分 誰かが自分に何か酷いことを言う
言われたらものすごくもう激怒する
怒って怒鳴って 喧嘩して
それで怒った人を言った人が申し訳ない
すいませんとか なんとかしてその問題を解決するでしょ？なんか自分が勝ったつもりでしょ
それで終わりますかね
消えませんね あれが その場で怒鳴って向こう謝ったら終わっちゃえばまた仲直りできればいいんで
そうならないんですね
ずーっとその恨み 憎しみ
もう自分をもう蝕むんですよ
だからそれが悪いと 人に何か言われたっても怒る
怒ってはいけませんと
怒りが現れをしたっても
やっぱりこの場で怒りませんと
心は汚せませんと言って
もう辛抱強く自分をコントロールすると
それで家に帰ってあれを思い出したっても
あいつは私にあんな失礼なこと言ったのに
私は怒らなかったなとかね
私はすごい冷静にいたな
我ながらかなりできたもんじゃないかなとかね
と思えるんですよ 自信ついたと
あとは他の人に何か言われたっても
大丈夫やと 乗り越えられるんだと
という気持ちになるでしょ
それが禅なんですね だから怒った人に対して怒らないことがすごい禅なんです
それが延々と自分の幸福を増やしてくれる
自信つけてくれる 力強くなるんです
だから善不善の定義は
幸福になる道は善で 不幸になる道は不善で
幸福 不幸っていうのはお金で計算しないでください
お金ではないんです お金っていうのは最近人間作ったもんで
生命の基本的なものじゃないんです
生命っていうのは この時空の世界でずっと昔から生き続けているんだから
それはもうお金とは関係ないんです
心の問題なんです この最近でしょ
みんな幸福と成功と言った途端
お金が頭に入ってくるのは
だったらお金使わなかった時代って
みんな不幸でしたかな
お金はなかった時代で
いわゆるそういう概念もなかった時代で
もしかすると将来的にお金は死ぬかもしれませんでしょ
全部電子信号になっちゃって
そうすると将来の人間が不幸だと
お金がないんだからと
ということにはならないんです
やっぱり生きるということはいつでも同じことで
ですから 幸福 不幸は心の状態で計算するもの
本当に喜びを感じて 充実感を感じて
我ながら結構頑張ってるんだぞと
うまくいってるんだよというふうな気持ちで生きていられることが禅の道なんです
ですから 悪をする人は確実に悩むという理屈は成り立つんです
いいことをする人は確実に喜ぶという理屈は
そういう時点でもう結論はつけるんです
だから 私たちに見える世界だけ見て
あの人はうまくいってるじゃないかという話ではないんですね
一応そこら辺で話を終了したいんです
ですから 今日覚えてほしいことは
自分で一人で自慢できるような人間になってみたらいかがでしょうかということをお釈迦様は言ってない
そんなこと言わないんです
で これは自分の判断ですからね
一応法則はそういう法則なんです
[背景音楽]